this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 68 Echo Charles sitting here
this is a echo Charles topic
and and it's it's a topic that look you
sent me a lot of topics yes most of them
I don't
most of them don't make the cut I'm just
being straight up you reject them I
reject them yes sir
because some of them I don't really get
s
some of them like I don't understand how
that's interesting but okay but you know
we're flowing with it okay but I will
say this last two undergrounds I have
been your
input okay so we're you know progress is
being made we'll say outstanding
but this one what's interesting about
this one there's something something
that you've heard me say yes which is
your kids won't be what you want them to
be they'll be who they are
as a topic and it's something that we've
talked about before that
your kids and if you have more than one
kid you know that your kids they're
they're genetically
predisposed to be a certain way like
they're just gonna be a certain way
you can influence that way somewhat but
sometimes man they're gonna be just
different
and in my opinion
the more you try and control them
the more
they possibly
can rebel against that thing that ideal
that you're trying to push them towards
now here's why I was
why I think this is a good subject
because that's one part of the topic
here's the when you take that topic
right there to me it's not just about
for kids this is about humans this is
about all people
and while we do have influence over
people our kids our employees our bosses
our peers we have info you have
influence all over all kinds of people
but they are going to be who they are
and you if you try and get them to
change by imposing on them it's not
going to work as effectively as you
might wish hey look is there a small
tiny percentage of the population that
is just hey will you
will you coach me will you Mentor me and
they really want it and they really will
there's a tiny percentage of population
that are like that tiny it's tiny
most people are like oh will you coach
me but I got my own way of doing things
you know oh will you coach me because I
think I can learn from you and then make
it better like that's the way most
people think
so the best way to influence people is
through the indirect methodology
what do I mean by that setting a good
example I think this is so powerful
and what's really hard about this one is
it takes years
people have to see you for a long time
setting a certain example before they go
you know what that's a pretty good way
of doing things it doesn't it does they
don't go wow that was cool I respect the
way Echoes handling that relationship
I'm gonna do the same thing it doesn't
work like occasionally
but most of the time you just set an
example and over time it osmoses it into
people's brains if you're overbearing
with the example hmm
then it becomes then then you become
like you're flexing your example all the
time and you're trying to show how good
you are at this thing it it becomes
off-putting and it's not going to help
if you want to influence someone
indirectly you got to build a
relationship with them right and how do
you build a relationship trustless and
respect and influence is something we
talk a whole time about a Echelon front
if if I want to influence you I could
allow you to influence me if I want you
to trust me I gotta trust you if I want
you to listen to me I gotta listen to
you this is what we talk about all the
time
by the way this applies with your kids
by the way this applies with your
employees your peers your bosses
everybody
asking Earnest questions
another important
methodology for steering people
it's so much better to say hey where are
you trying to get to than to say take a
right or take a left or keep going in
that same direction now it's look that
works more while we're driving a car
even when you're driving a car by the
way that can piss people off you're like
hey you're hey you need to take a left
here bro what are you talking about you
don't even know where we're going I'm
driving I have my GPS up what are you
talking about why are you talking to me
that can be offensive just trying to
tell someone the road directions can
piss people off right that's why there's
a literal term for it backseat driver
There's an actual term we have for don't
freaking directly tell people how to
drive because it pisses them off hey you
need to slow down hey you need to speed
up hey you need to back off say that to
my wife
while she's driving I dare you
I dare you to say uh uh hey you're
you're a little close to that car I dare
you to say that to her
see what happens see how that Direct
effort to influence my wife on how far
she's tailgating somebody from yeah
right you know what I'm saying I know
exactly what you're saying sir yes how
does how does Sarah Charles react to
these scenarios
um well
it's been a while
um
[Music]
we're not playing she hasn't learned it
but oh no oh see even Echo Charles gets
a little heated everybody gets heated
with direct so that's weird that's such
a perfect metaphor no one likes to get
told how to drive yeah now you think
they want to get told how to live
it doesn't happen
you know have you ever told someone
hey you should you should don't tailgate
so close and they were like oh thanks
for telling me I'll back off a little
bit does that happen in your life
whatever it's never happened in my life
I was with a friend of mine
he got caught off by a motorcycle brutal
and and like the guy like kind of
flipped him off
okay yeah and my friend
was driving and started driving
exceedingly fast I want to chase him to
chase him and and got to him and started
following him at like
the most insanely dangerous
proximity and I'm like bro stop what
you're doing this is not
like didn't help at all
in fact he accelerated right yeah
yep thankfully we had to turn off the
highway yeah but I was like dude but but
this is such a perfect example because
you know you're dry you know your wife
is driving too close to that vehicle
yeah you know it
but she doesn't want to hear that
from you so that's the way life is and
when you try and direct people and from
the backseat driver that's the reason
why
you're the backseat driver and they
don't want to hear it so what you have
to do is you have to use the indirect
approach
that's what you have to do
so you say
uh
uh you know
hey what kind of car is that did they
cut you off so you say that
um who no no no they didn't cut me off I
was just wondering because you're like
right up on them
you might get away with that even that
be too direct right yeah
so
asking Earnest questions building
relationships that's the way we have to
focus this if you want to influence
people to change their their behavior
and life and their methodology for
driving you have to take the indirect
approach now here's another positive way
to get this done give people ownership
[Music]
give people ownership people like
to be their own boss
most people I'm gonna say 70 of people
like to have ownership they like to have
control actually more than that
in life everybody wants to have control
over their life 99 97 of people yeah
want to have control over what's going
on
so when people in their life
when you give them responsibility
it's it's it's positive for them
when you say and I answered a question
like this on the academy today it's like
oh we're gonna work in an industry where
you can't give them any ownership
hmm
even in the most stringent of businesses
or Industries like nuclear power one of
the strictest industries that we work
with nuclear power
if there's a protocol for how you enter
a building
okay there's and I go and you're the guy
that's in charge of the building and I
say hey here's the protocol follow the
protocol you have a little Grudge
you have a little Grudge now if I say
hey Echo here's a protocol we've been
using the past I know you just got here
let me know if there's any changes that
you think need to be made this is what
we've been using all of a sudden you're
stoked I gave you ownership I gave you
ownership of an existing protocol
but I gave it to you instead of saying
hey instead of imposing it on you I I
gave you ownership of it
so if you could do that in life it's
going to help people in a big way
to take ownership
and then what you do is you can ask
questions about where they're going and
we had an interesting conversation with
Chris Voss
and he pointed out the fact which I
agree with
that the word why is an accusatory word
right hey why are you doing this why are
you tailgating that car yeah that's it's
an accusatory Ward which is an
interesting
scenario because as you know at Echelon
front and from a leadership perspective
we talk a lot about explaining the why
and so you've got to explain the why so
you'd think that okay then you also
should be asking why
but I agree with the fact that asking
someone hey why are you doing it like
that can put people defensive
immediately so instead if you say
something like hey what you know hey
what's your end goal that you're trying
to achieve here or
what is it you're trying to get to or
you know hey how does this fit hey how
does this
how does it fit in your long-term goals
if you can ask those kind of questions
they can be less accusatory and some of
them you could still ask accusatory
questions it doesn't matter what word
you so you have to be careful
but
asking Earnest questions about where
people are going that help them discover
the truth is the way to go
and treating here's here's uh two
similarities in life
so you know I wrote about leadership
strategy and tactics one of my favorite
methodologies for training people
is putting them in leadership positions
because what you do when you do that is
you you give them responsibility you
give them ownership and it's a positive
thing it's the same methodology that I
have for kids which is if you treat kids
like an adult
it gives them responsibility it makes
them Step Up
now look I'm not saying you you know
throw them out in the streets and say
figure it out but to say oh you got to
make your own breakfast in the morning
I'm not making your lunch before you
know if your kid
is I can't think of the exact age maybe
six or seven years old they should be
able to make their own lunch for school
you gotta say I can't remember the ages
yeah what do you think six years old
make your own lunch my boy will not
can't make his own lunch at this time
he's six but what if you trained him
yeah I could train him for sure so right
now you're just letting him suffer yeah
that's one way to put it for sure no I
mean you're letting you're making him
come dependent yes that is one way to
put it yeah put it this way actually now
that I'm thinking about this consciously
in this direct way for the first time I
pre yes I probably could begin the
training process that's about now yeah
so let's say six years old you begin the
training process for you make your own
lunch you get your own clothes out you
have your book bag packed yes when
you're ready to go you come tell me
that it's time to go to school yeah
right this is the opposite of where
everyone else is like hey gotta go hurry
up get your shoes on yeah we gotta go no
maybe that's eight
might be only because well then again
I'm only thinking about my I've only had
one well I've had a six-year-old
daughter before too but I can't remember
that a little while ago but currently
if I say this is my prediction because I
haven't done it yet but if I say hey you
tell me when you're ready oh we're late
100 probably okay then you have to be
able to deal with the consequences okay
hey son you're late that means you're
gonna get in trouble at school that
means you're not gonna be able to go to
recess
that's not on me that's on you you're
responsible and you start to treat kids
like an adult and they'll start to take
responsibility and take ownership and
that is how you get your kids
to be who they are but to be the the
best version of themselves that you can
hope for that's my recommendation
yeah you you I got this idea from from
you directly oh and it was like once I
kind of accepted that you know because
perhaps like one of the one of the many
people who was like you know before you
have kids you see other people have kids
you're like yeah I'm gonna be like
for like I mean put maybe to simplify it
I'll be like I'm not gonna make those
mistakes like whenever I got it kind of
thing yeah yeah well I know what I'm
gonna do you know
so and I think that's a common thing for
sure and then when you get in you know
the first you know the expression from
Mike Tyson he said yeah everybody has a
plan until they get punched in their
face so it was really that really it was
like it was one step from that in my
opinion how it felt where yeah when
you're in it bro you know bro these kids
are acting all different than I expected
like and I just thought oh yeah all I
got to do is be consistent and say this
and you know whatever but it doesn't
even work like our own brains not even
close I was like dang and certain things
that were working that I was like that
would never work but it's like oh
it's interesting how that works so
easily so
so it it's it's hard there's a lot going
on you know we'll see
um and then here's the part that it's
hard to even predict even a little bit
is we all think we're going to be
perfect well not we all but in my case
I kind of maybe subconsciously thought I
was gonna just handle everything perfect
why would I lose the temper of a kid
it's just a kid why would I be mad at
that why would I get frustrated you know
it's just a kid
but man you're like a human I'm a human
being too you know and I'm not gonna be
perfect 100 of every interaction every
minute of every day like that's not
gonna happen obviously and then quite
frankly it's not even gonna come close
to that
so you're going to react in certain ways
sometimes right sometimes wrong and then
that's going to influence them in a
certain way and make them develop in a
certain way so it's like bro there's no
way you can just make them be who you
want to be bro they're going to be who
they're gonna be um so you're not gonna
be perfect they're not gonna be perfect
as far as your little plan kind of a
thing and man the the soon when I
accepted that I was like bro there's so
many factors and man all you can do is
literally like do the best you can kind
of thing learn as much as you can for
sure yep now just to point out to
everybody this is not surrender yeah
it's not going well the hell with it I
mean my kids no the most the best way to
have the most positive influence over
your kids to steer them in the right
direction and give them the best
possible life is by taking this
methodology
if you do the like well I just need to
go harder your kids
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground